o que você pode fazer por você agora há
cinco anos e meio eu fiz algo por mim eu
sai às ruas pela primeira vez em são
paulo para ajudar pessoas desconhecidas
com a pergunta o que eu posso fazer por
você agora
naquele 5 de junho de 2013
mal sabia eu que era um desconhecido que
me habita quem mais estava me ajudando
carla ferro disse o lugar para cair em
si é o outro mas antes deixou de contar
essa minha jornada vou contar um pouco
da minha história até subir aqui neste
palco
eu tive pouco contato com os meus avós
mas eu tenho lembranças muito amorosos
dele deles
meu avô bem villar ele era chefe da
estação de trem chegará pava ele fez a
passagem para outro plano quando eu
tinha só dois anos então dele eu tenho
as primeiras lembranças da minha
infância eu sentado no colo dele ele
brincando de serra serra serra do cerro
papo do vovô
ele me deixava alguns segundos de cabeça
pra baixo e isso ficou em mim à minha
avó fiuka ela tinha uma voz inesquecível
lembro sempre da felicidade dela quando
ela me via e ela ia pra minha casa em
batatais e ela quando ela chegava lá
pegava todos os saquinhos de leite
lembra daquele saquinhos de leite ela
lavava bem lavado e colocava todos os
azuis nos azulejos da cozinha assim a
mãe ficava louca mas ela falava assim ah
eu vou levar para o hospital do fogo
selvagem e isso também ficou em mim meu
avô capitão manoel carneiro da cunha ele
tem uma rua em ribeirão preto com esse
nome o que é orgulho para toda a minha
família o meu avô lutou na segunda
guerra mundial ele tinha um caroço na
cabeça e quando eu era criança eu achava
que ele tinha levado um tiro de canhão
eu contava em si pra todo mundo
na verdade ele tinha levado só um
estilhaço de granada quando era pequena
eu adorava inventar vários mundos eu
vivia nesses mundos e isso ficou muito
a minha avó maria da conceição eu não a
conheci ela fez a passagem quando não
tinha chegado aqui ainda
mas durante muitos anos a minha mãe
achou que eu era a reencarnação dela
porque ela falou pra minha mãe que ela
tem uma filha que a dar muito trabalho
ela fala que acho que é você que voltou
minha mãe que voltou essa sou eu no meu
aniversário de 15 anos todas minhas
primas vestir rosa e eu estava de preto
sem nenhuma vontade de tirar foto
começou bom a minha mãe conta que meu
bisavô quintela e dizia as mãos que não
vivem para servir não serve para viver
continuando e isso também ficou em mim
continuando a minha história e me casei
três vezes e me separei as três
a primeira vez foi aos 20 anos eu me
separei os 22 e eu pensei minha vida
acabou
na segunda vez eu me casei aos 26min
separei aos 35 com um filho de quatro
anos e eu pensei o que vai ser da minha
vida agora do meu último casamento a
gente se separou há quatro anos foi uma
separação muito difícil para todos nós e
até hoje ainda penso quais são as
responsabilidades diante das das
histórias em que eu me meto de tudo isso
que aconteceu o melhor de tudo foi o
nascimento dos meus três filhos no hotel
do levy e da gaia e foi com eles ea
partir deles que comem comecei a pensar
que mundo eles vão encontrar quando eu
não estiver mais aqui
qualquer pequeno legado que eu posso
deixar pra eles e aí com esse sentimento
porque eu sempre fui uma criança depois
que um adolescente uma jovem muito
inconformada com as com todo o tipo de
desigualdade que permeia nossa vida eu
nunca fui indiferente às dores dos
nossos irmãos e sempre fiz o que estava
ao meu alcance para amenizar as jornadas
que cruzavam seu caminho
então foi esse com esse sentimento e um
sentimento também profundo de resgatar a
minha alma que estava sendo sugada pelo
meu ego e por trabalho por relações que
não faziam mais muito sentido pra mim
que eu comece
se contar de novo a história que eu te
contei quando eu comecei a subir neste
palco quando eu sair nas ruas pela
primeira vez pouco tempo depois o
material captado foi parar na internet e
depois na tv e quase um ano depois eu
fundei o instituto a nossa jornada
enfrentando muitos medos muitos
julgamentos desafios assustadores e hoje
eu conecto pessoas do mundo inteiro
unindo quem precisa de ajuda a quem pode
ajudar sem nenhum patrocínio de nenhuma
empresa de nenhuma instituição a gente
já foi o ar para milhares de pessoas
seguirem a sua jornada chegarem fôlego e
continuarem o seu caminho
a hillary a gente conseguiu pagar pra
ela um ano de saúde
ela tem uma síndrome muito muito rara e
vendendo as bonequinhas a 10 reais
a gente conseguiu pagar um plano de
saúde dela por um ano
agora pra cá voltando
aqui a gente conseguiu resgatar essas
três refugiados lado congo elas estavam
presas na floresta do congo foram
capturadas por exército do governo
levados pela floresta floresta essa
jornada chegou até nós lhes conseguiu
arrecadar um dinheiro aqui conseguimos
comprar essas meninas de volta tiramos o
passaporte delas belas 3 do pai
a gente está tentando trazê las para o
brasil a gente nesses últimos cinco anos
e meio aquecemos muitos irmãos em todos
os invernos que passaram por nosso
caminho
a gente conseguiu montar uma marca de
roupas chamada cabia lá na áfrica no
quênia com refugiados do congo que
chegavam lá no natal de 2017 a gente fez
uma loja de brinquedos para crianças
órfãs e refugiados em são paulo é porque
eu acredito que todo mundo tem o poder
de escolha
a gente dá aula de inglês todos os
sábados no jardim branco era em são
paulo a gente acolhe todos os refugiados
que chegam até nós através do projeto
bem vindo você chega em casa a gente dá
outro português todos os sábados e
colocamos eles no mercado de trabalho
temos causa carinho que mais eles
precisarem nesses últimos cinco anos a
gente realizou muitos sonhos
a gente conseguiu fazer a gente consegue
pagar e viabilizar três faculdades
adriano e medicina 2010 e não em
salvador
o jack ruby em psicologia no quênia eo
fred em são paulo
de gestão ambiental deixa oferece café
da manhã todos os sapos dos moradores de
rua em são paulo
estamos criando uma cooperativa de
costura resgatando famílias que vivem
ainda na escravidão da exploração da
indústria têxtil
a jornada foi muito importante pra mim
eu estava na minha casa um dia recebi um
e mail de uma pessoa dizendo eu tenho
três crianças dormindo aqui imagina
ladeira e minha dispensa estão assim ela
só tô comendo na escola gostaria muito
que você me ajudasse
e foi num projecto que eu vou conseguir
mas eu prometo que vou tentar
e aí eu tentei e comecei a mandar várias
mensagens em uma semana depois ela me
manda essa mesma foto da geladeira
pensa eu falo a gente ajuda uma única
vez cada pessoa pra você pegar o fôlego
e continuar sua jornada
tudo que eu faço isso que eu faço é
ativismo eo ativismo está em nossas mãos
e foi andando de mãos dadas com essas
pessoas e com outras tantas pessoas e
ouvindo essas e outras tantas histórias
que eu comecei a encontrar as respostas
pra minha vida esse movimento de cuidar
do outro de olhar para o outro porque a
qual só quando a gente olha para o outro
com compaixão é que a gente realmente se
olha e quando eu te conto essas
histórias e as histórias dessas pessoas
você não me acesso nem acesso a essas
pessoas mas você acessa assim ser
ilimitado que habita
agora como é que eu fiz tudo isso né já
que não tem bens materiais e moro de
aluguel
meu carro é 2011 financiado em 60 vezes
meu filho meus filhos têm bons escolar
eu pago um preço bem alto por alguns
encontros e por ter sido um pouco
ingênua inexperiente em alguns encontros
que eu fiz por pela minha vida antes de
contar como eu faço o que eu faço é
preciso de dizer eu tenho primeiro tenho
vários empregos eu faço várias coisas o
roteirista e diretora artística vendo
coisas faça palestras porque eu ajudo
muita gente mas antes de contar mais
sobre isso eu preciso de dizer que
enquanto eu era reconhecida por fazer o
bem que pra mim não é mais do que
precisa ser feito
a minha vida pessoal de morona vá eu
saía do meu terceiro casamento de uma
forma muito violenta e eu estava à beira
de uma falência financeira o que
realmente aconteceu em 2016 eu estava em
casa com os meus filhos e eu abri a
geladeira pra dar um lanche para eles a
tarde e só tinha três fatias de pães e
uma maionese na geladeira atrasar vários
cachês que eu tinha para receber naquele
mês
eu falei o que eu vou fazer eu fiquei
muito assustado naquele momento e aí eu
lembrei que os meus filhos tinham três
cofrinhos 342 cofrinhos cada 16 ficou
feliz peguei todos os cofrinhos coloquei
em cima da mesa
a juntar às moedas de r$350 moedas e aí
foi instintivo que eu peguei o telefone
liguei no orfanato perto da minha casa
foi que estão precisando
ela falou a gente precisa de biscoito a
gente vai dar café da tarde para as
crianças só têm café com leite
eu peguei comecei para todas as moedas
peguei r$300 coloquei em uma sacola e aí
3 50 reais na outra
fui à padaria trocar fim marcado
supermercado comprei 50 reais de
biscoitos e comprei presenciais de
comida para casa teria fiquei bastante
assustada sentem de várias coisas
entende que quando o mesmo quando você
acha que você não tem nada pra
compartilhar você tem sim para
compartilhar
aprendi que mesmo aquele dia eu não ia
conseguir alimentar três crianças e
alimentei 43 crianças
aprendi que não são as dificuldades a
gente não sai do lugar quando o que
imaginar que a minha casa tinha 350
reais moedas e principalmente eu entendi
e quando a gente cuida do outro universo
cuida da gente e foi vivendo esses
aprendizados dolorosos assustadores que
eu sigo a minha jornada ea jornada como
o instituto com o nosso instituto assim
oferecendo o meu melhor
aquilo que eu posso aquilo que eu dou
conta naquele momento
diante da expectativa do outro ele
sempre acha que você pode fazer melhor
talvez amanhã eu possa fazer diferente
com os recursos que a vida me oferece a
todo instante
esse é o grande segredo faça sempre o
seu melhor
faça o que você dá conta tudo muda o
tempo todo eu não sou mais a mesma
pessoa que subiu nesse palco nem vocês
são as mesmas pessoas que chegaram aqui
nem somos as mesmas pessoas que vão
voltar pra casa
se você acha que você poderia ter feito
diferente alguma coisa que você fez
ontem é porque você já não é mais aquela
pessoa e lenta
lembre-se tudo passa busco profundamente
o autoconhecimento porque é só quando a
gente se conhece que a gente consegue
conhecer o outro respeitar o outro
o autoconhecimento nada mais é do que
você descobrir os seus limites rede
descobriu ser ilimitado que habita e
principalmente perceber o que a sua
sombra tem pra te ensinar
compartilhe compartilhe que você tem e
compartilhar não é dividir é partilhar
quanto mais você partilha mais bênçãos e
prosperidades chegaram até você
quanto mais você compartilha o que você
tem mais você tem aquilo que você
compartilha entregue seus sonhos ao
poder supremo que nos rege trabalho na
direção deles
mas não fiquem obcecados por eles
aprenda ensine ajude o outro a
reconhecer o que ele tem de bom que cada
vez que a gente julga alguém
a única coisa que a gente faz é
expressar nossa própria opinião e isso é
uma perda de tempo uma perda de energia
cada vez que a gente julga alguém a
gente simplesmente coloca no outro coisa
que você não vê o que conseguiu é
resolver em você mesmo
nunca faça promessas que não possa
cumprir tenha compaixão por todos os
seres que cruzaram seu caminho todos os
seres
por que eles estão passando ou eles vão
passar
eles passaram por uma dor muito profunda
assim como você
por isso seja o ar a pessoa pegar fôlego
e continuar a sua jornada e não se
escureça
diante da menor possibilidade de ajudar
um ser vivo
nada é nossa nem o ar que a gente está
respirando agora é nossa porque a gente
tem que devolver o inverso
assim são todas as coisas
tudo o que é teu não é teu tudo o que é
teu emprestado pra você cuidar por um
tempo e também consegui fazer o que eu
faço porque tenho pessoas incríveis ao
meu lado e ajudando nessa caminhada e
90% das pessoas que me ajudam e que
pedem ajuda são mulheres
então nós mulheres ea todos sagrado
feminino que mora em todos
nós eu quero lembrar de um livro da
clareza picolés tis mulheres que correm
com os lobos que ela disse
ela disse não se desgaste com a raiva
muito pelo contrário muito pelo
contrário
pegamos forças dela não sejamos espertas
e usemos nossos talentos femininas seja
como a velha cadeira de balanço que
embalam a ideia até que ela volte a
remoçar seja como a mulher da história
do uso da meia lua que aprendi a ver
além da ilusão não se distraia queimando
fósforos e fantasias com uma pequena
menina dos fósforos
não desista até encontrar a real família
à qual pertence como patinho feio como a
donzela sim mãos desde que o coração
paciente ag floresta fora como la loba
recolher os ossos os valores perdidos e
cante os para devolvê-los à vida
perdoe tanto quanto puder
esqueça um pouco e cria muito o que você
faz hoje influencia suas descendentes no
futuro as filhas das suas filhas das
suas filhas irão provavelmente
lembrar-se de você o que é mais
importante a seguir o seu exemplo
eu desejo que vocês escolham as suas
histórias com sabedoria e que aceitem
aceitem os desafios as perdas aceitem as
alegrias e as tristezas aceitem as
bênçãos que te esperam aceitem aceite
você suas falhas e suas vitórias porque
quando nós aceitamos a vida fica mais
leve que ser vivida e honre honre seus
amores ou em sua casa
seus pais honrem seus filhos morrem seus
amigos sua família e não percam os seus
sonhos de vista que não há nada mais
20 do que uma ideia em que o tempo
chegou
obrigado
[Aplausos]